hello everyone I'm here to tell you a
story today
it was the Ramadan of 2017 in
Johannesburg a few months after I
started working as a photographer and I
pitched the story to an editor saying I
would like to photograph the taraweeh as
a contemporary look at Islam in South
Africa and he replied
nobody cares about Muslims in South
Africa if we want something we'll take
it from Saudi or Turkey
I am South African I am Muslim I am also
a woman of color who grew up in a little
town called Ladysmith M lambda T in
kwazulu-natal during the dying years of
apartheid so I knew very well what it
was like to live and attorney to be
treated as less than human or worse or
to be invisible and I was not going to
act like we did not exist no matter
anymore
how many of you here know that the first
Muslims in Southern Africa some of my
ancestors were taken as slaves and
political prisoners from Indonesia by
the Dutch in the 1600s and that because
of this history and in later years the
forced and voluntary migration that
South Africa has one of the most diverse
Muslim populations in the world or that
in the slave communities it was Islam
that became a rallying point to build
unity around and that Muslims were
prominent in the anti-apartheid struggle
so I photograph the taraweeh anyway and
put up the picture that night on
Instagram another editor saw it and
called me and asked if I would
photograph for the entire month and we
would do a double page spread on the day
of the Eid celebration it was also
around this time when a Dutch ambassador
saw my work and said oh I didn't know
there were Muslims in South Africa how
did they get there
there were shocked faces in his
delegation which mirrored my own but
still not my heart when he remarked
about the white domination and said oh
yes we did a lot of mischief back there
then mischief he called it it is not
just ignorance it is irrational so we
never truly saw ourselves in our own
history books and this is why the work
we do now is so important with this
project I hope to create something that
generations to come can look upon as a
source of history and memory and I've
barely even scratched the surface so far
mostly exploring spaces of worship of
prayer and observance together and in
solitude
with the embodiment of connectedness of
rootedness and reminiscence is visible
even so and already I am so grateful and
so proud to say that in 2019 this work
was acquired by the South African easy
core national museum and gallery to be
part of the archive and permanent
collection and will now form part of our
country's historical visual memory thank
you
for me this is a testament to how hungry
we are to see ourselves dignified in
these public and institutional spaces
everything that I do with my work and
the people who I photograph for stories
and themes of social justice paid access
to water and sanitation or safe housing
food safety and gender-based violence
give an equal education plastic
pollution climate change everything
everything is inevitably and
inextricably linked to the structural
and systemic legacies of our colonial
and apartheid past and so every single
day I see resilience I see strength
I see dignity and pride the industry of
photography is not separate to the
industry to the world which we
photograph not only are so many of us
here from these very disadvantaged
communities but the question of what
story is yet to get told who gets to
tell them and how stole remains linked
to a legacy of access of privilege and
of power and still beat in the field or
in this room of narrators I see stories
of triumph and people who are here and
achieving things despite our odds and
this this is the story of the majority
world a favorite verse of mine from
Quran can be translated with the meaning
of humankind we have created you from
male and female into nations and tribes
so that you may know one another so that
we may know one another to truly know
one another we first have to see each
other as equals even if just in our own
humanity and to see each other well we
first have to care enough to want to do
so since that Ramadan in 27
one of the things that give me gives me
purpose in my work is to never again be
faced with the statement that nobody
cares about the people because to care
well that is the least very least that
we can do thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
and now please welcome to the stage
journalist author and 2019 National
Geographic Eliza sit more awardee David
Kwan in conversation with visual
storyteller and National Geographic
fellow Erica Larsen she's the bull rider
for this segment
and I am the rodeo clown but I'm really
glad to be here because I love her work
and she's a friend of mine for 10 years
more than 10 years erica has been going
to some of the most remote places on the
planet cold places and hot places and
paying careful attention to some of the
most remote people in the world and the
cultures that they live in and you're
gonna be seeing it we're gonna start
with a little bit of the mundane and
personal and then we're going to move
toward the magical and universal do you
remember the first photo you ever sold I
don't remember but I remember the first
photo I ever saw or that meant something
to me which was what so it was a picture
from the Hubble of Saturn and I remember
holding it in my hands and in that
moment you realize that everything
that's so far away is so close to you
and you were above it and it is of you
and it existed in a photo and then I
thought that photo that photography is
magic and magic can remind you of who
you are and then who we're gonna be how
old were you dad I don't remember but
maybe I was 11 something like that I
don't remember so when you remind me
where you grew up I was born here just
right here on stage no I was Indian yeah
is born in DC but I grew up on the
Eastern Shore of Maryland
and when you were in high school and
finishing high school and going to
college what were the expectations of
your family and your friends about what
you were going to be what you were going
to do what did people think Erika was
going to become what was the pressure or
the expectation oh I know that my mom
said to me that she said I could be my
mother was a cook in the home and I
could be a teacher
and you can she said you can do whatever
you feel in your heart and I will
support it with everything and I said I
want to be a part of this photography
magic and my father went and got some
kind of camera some DSL or whatever it
is SLR camera and put it around his neck
and that was that again how old roughly
17 okay and you went to college and
majored in photography right I did
finishing that when did you reach the
point where you could say now I am gonna
be a photographer and only a
photographer I can give my life to
photography I can afford it
the world is letting me do it well I
never looked at it that way ever I think
there's something about you know when
you realize that it does exist and that
you're a part of this collective idea of
how we can translate the world
it's not about that's it then you just
are I think it's like right once you
know something you can't Unknowing
and so that was it that it so I'm not
even sure it was about photography or
not in that regard whether oh it's
something that I can continue to do or
not do it's just that now it is and
you'll have to do it so it's um I don't
it just is you weren't always a
photographer of remote places and remote
people you want a World Press Photo
Award for sports photography mm-hmm what
was that about
well you saw some of it it was actually
the young girl standing there I don't
know the little girl there in the she
had the camel on in the wood so it was
about children and hunting and the idea
was to understand why children that
didn't live a subsistence lifestyle
wanted to be engaged in hunting and so I
think the world I didn't enter in the
sports category I think somebody put it
in the sports category I'm not kidding I
think at the time world press kind of I
might have entered it in portrait and I
think they put it in the sports category
but the idea is so I didn't really think
of it my wasn't about sport but it was
about you know why why we wanted to
connect with nature when maybe and all
the reasons you think you don't need to
so that was the exploration and then
somebody else related it to sport but
okay even even then that theme was there
mm-hmm
the Sami people for years you lived with
the Sami people as a a viga biga mm-hmm
tell us what that was so biga is well
traditionally there was a woman that
would come in from maybe a family that
wouldn't have had as many resources
meaning at that point reindeer and so it
would go to another family and help and
do things and so that could be from
cooking to cleaning to helping with the
children but ultimately that one of the
most important things is that you would
you know travel with the families on on
tundra and then also you would you would
slaughter the animals and so you would
and so Amin when you think about that if
the bigger gets to slaughter the animal
is the most important part of that
connection to these cycles of life and
death and they celebrated that so it
occurs to me we should add in case
anybody doesn't know the Sami are the
reindeer herding people of northern
Scandinavian so the animals that you're
slaughtering yeah means that they were
taking care of a reindeer you've said on
tape about that that four year project
you learned the language you lived with
them you stay
and you said I came here in search of
silence so that I could begin to hear
again this is a journal entry that
you've read on tape a journal entry
while you were there
I came here in search of silence so that
I could begin to hear again I am now
more a stranger in my own home than I am
here help us understand what led you to
do that I'm gonna go spend four years
with the Sami in northern Norway you
were in your early 30s about that point
right you had been a photographer been a
professional photographer did you come
to some sort of a crisis point or a
point of discomfort with your own life
in the South I was in New York City at
the time so I think there came a point I
was I had been working a lot on at doing
a lot of editorial work but really
amazing work but kind of going in and
out of families and it sort of existed
on two levels I was working with a lot
of you know maybe in our demographic of
like 60 and over and a lot about how we
and that age group deal with what it is
to to get older our relationship to
family our relationship to landscape our
relationship to death but also how we
perceive the world so dementia
Alzheimer's and these so I was doing a
lot of stories on that and then I was
also working a lot with adolescents and
so things around you know what it is to
be a teenager mostly in in society in
the United States the whole range of it
and I said and it was amazing but I
realized that for my own eye so I think
I was constantly dealing with themes of
life and death but in these situations
and I had begun my personal work
exploring hunting to take a different
look at life and death that was removed
from the human or what I perceived as
the human because it actually isn't but
but what I perceived is the human
emotion around it
and and then from that it was getting
these glimpses of seeing when I would go
on these hunts I would realize spending
time kind of deeper time in nature away
from a place like New York City and even
away from these sort of familial
situations that I was living in these
homes I mean I could feel like this kind
of beginning of like a fine-tuned
instrument starting to happen and as I
would see animals maybe I could begin to
see these ancestral stories and then I
realized it's our story like our human
story and you could see that through and
I thought my goodness if I it's so it's
not that you're telling stories you're
remembering them and it was really
strong and I said I have to learn to
hear again because I have a glimpse of
it but I need to so I needed to break
all the parts and begin to hear again
and that's and then I thought okay so
where can I do that moon so I first went
to the Amazon I don't know why but
that's very one and I realized in that
time it wasn't where I was meant to be
it was like going into this dark dark
dark ground underneath but that's where
I found my son and I found my husband
that wasn't time yet and then I said
what's the opposite of the Amazon and
I'm sure scientifically it's not this
but I thought what is it and I said
that's Arctic and I went to the Arctic
and I that was and you just everyone
just got to see genja so maybe from what
you underfoot which which she just
translated the Arctic it's there's
something right it's something that this
land holds and so that's why I went for
years you had found your husband
you had your son not yet I had found
them both but had
we started this he started this
afternoon with oceans and you have to
understand that this woman is as deep as
an ocean let's talk a little bit about
ritual you've said that ritual and
you've put it on the slides an
exploration of ritual it's sort of the
overriding theme of your collected body
of work and the grant work recently
ritual especially in the lives of remote
peoples what do you mean when you say as
you've said to me and I I think you said
in other places ritual allows us to
explore time well I'm still learning
what that means and perhaps I always
will be but I have I have a belief in so
for my life that you know as we're
trying to understand so I believe we're
remembering who we are to be humans
right I think that's what for me that's
what this journeys about it's this
process of remembering who we are and so
in that we have to we get confronted
with our perceptions of time and you
know on the most basic level right every
culture holds a different understanding
of what time is and how to how to
express it and how to teach us about
that
and so I've I've gone through different
phases of watching time be one thing and
then become another and then I realized
that that in order for to understand the
next sort of level of hi I'm experienced
in time I need a place of liminal space
and the mental space is this moment when
you know everything is but but isn't
it's the time of before but after and I
think it's also a really difficult time
but within that that's when you can sort
of like break break the concept of what
you had perceived the moment before and
then I I realized that um you know when
I'm watching ritual and whatever ritual
is whether it's washing dishes where
there's a prescribed ritual that's been
going on for
thousand years but when you're watching
ritual it is a time for for this liminal
space to exist and within them in all
space we can all begin to have that
moment to connect to what it means to be
human
so liminal space transitional space yeah
I think it's transitional space I think
it's the green room space there's a
there's a line from William Faulkner
that you just put me in mind of from his
book light in August think it starts the
fifth chapter he's telling these deep
stories about some really troubled
fraught people and the chapter begins
memory believes before knowing remembers
does that make any sense to you in terms
of what you're thinking yeah absolutely
and I've heard it different ways that on
the future is the past but yet the past
is the future I think I was talking to
someone last night and my doings gonna
block it out but they said and it's but
we're always in contradiction
we're in contradictions as to what we
think so then you have this and it's
going to like you know it's
contradictory over here so yes I think
it makes a bit of sense but I think the
fact that it doesn't make sense is what
keeps us on the exploration yeah
let's look at and talk about some of
these particular images okay yes if I
can find the ones that I went to ask you
about excuse me if we just okay so this
is probably the end of that loop and now
we're starting okay
let me just ask you about that why does
a hunter collect bare feet I don't know
why why we collect anything but I think
collection is I believe in that the
things that we experience there's
there's many levels of it in there one
level is our physical manifestation of
and the Earth's physical manifestation
of all of these things so therefore it
becomes our collection I I don't think
all hunters collect I think many do and
all don't what I think is that hunters
guide us many guide us to look at the
one thing that's difficult right we are
looking at our death and we're looking
at what it means to bring death and
because there's a part of it also that
we feel there's the idea of sustenance
and so how we live and how we take is
part of the sort of larger ecosystem of
life and death and what we need to live
and survive in so there's many things
that were questioning so I see the
hunters less as collectors but guides
into that but I think many collect this
photo is also part of your hunting group
this is the the one that won the sports
thing so this is a North American girl
yes it was part of a hunting family her
name's Mary she's from Georgia and she's
probably in her 20s now okay well the
thing that I want to ask you about is
what might connect this photo with some
of the later photos and I'm going to
jump ahead to them but but freeze this
photo in your mind this photo of Mary in
her camo Mary in full camo and why does
a person wear camo because it's a
pattern that connects you with nature
right is that fair I think that's very
fair
okay there's there we go okay the lady
on the right and that pattern so this is
stuff that I'm very I don't know but
this is what my exploration is trying to
understand so I think that we are
interpreting the world around us right I
believe or for me that the journey is
that nature because by remembering we're
all remembering that we are nature I
believe so we are of nature it's exactly
what you're doing in your books in the
way that you do it we're remembering
this and as we remember it we need to
put it out there we need to physically
manifest it in these different ways so
you know Realtree did it for Mary and
and this woman here she's wearing the
the her acardo's or her her songs of of
her interpretation of her landscape and
in the rainforest of Peru and but it was
interesting and again this is my
interpretation of the understanding of
it this is not her words or who she is
but as I am but right so so it's it's
the patterns of of actual the physical
nature we see the patterns we see on on
the animals on the snakes
it's the patterns that she's able to
verbalize through her voice and then it
becomes a physical pattern but then at
the same time it's actually the internal
pattern of our DNA makeup as well so
it's all of these things put together
and it's just one translation and we all
have our translation of that we're all
translating this this is the people who
have that idea of ken a which is the
pattern and they you call them
people have Ronan the great serpent it's
an important animal for them
the Anaconda yes because the Anaconda
has all of the patterns all of the
patterns of the world of their world of
their translation of the world of our
world of the collective world and so the
snake has it there's ever-changing
patterns and there's never - that never
ends and it never doesn't end and here
you can hear singing singing the pattern
do I need a good time okay
the woman on the left that's Emma full
moon what is she thinking I don't know
what I was thinking um these are the
people who live with and from salmon yes
yeah so this is um here we're in Alaska
with with a community of you pick I
don't know what Emma thinks but I will
tell you about the first time I met Emma
so you walk into a place I walked into
quinna Hawke it's like a village of 600
people and obviously everyone's gonna
know that you're not from Quinn Hawke so
you're walking down the street and I
thought it's a horrible horrible feeling
and you know I feel like you're like
it's a horrible feeling to walk in and
just Matt so I just I found a walrus
hanging on a door and I thought well I
want to go go where that walrus I was it
was the walrus skull that full Wohlers
wasn't there just the skull and I walked
and I knocked on the door and Emma
answered the door and I just introduced
myself and she said okay come in and I
just she just I sat down on the floor
and she was just cleaning berries he's
just cleaning berries so I again I don't
know what's in Emma's thought but what I
can say is that she expresses herself by
the things that she does by opening the
door and just cleaning the berries by
letting me see this moment by a gesture
that shall do so okay
this is a seal the seal yeah I want to
bounce a well let's listen to this okay
so I can't vomit my balls
what was that
so in this village so the story goes and
devout Allah say they yeah okay there
you pick in in over the past 80 years
they because of the Christian
missionaries that went in the they
stopped dancing and they stopped
relating to their natural world in the
way that they always had in the way that
they would translate it and one of the
big things was dance they didn't stop
hunting but they stopped describing the
hunt in the same way and so we're we're
we're in the Western southwestern Alaska
and we're also right on the Bering Sea
and so as we're seeing this permafrost
melt happening you are watching of
you're watching sort of the land come up
things mountain you're watching these
rising sea levels and so this go down
and so in this huge transition that
you're seeing go on you're also seeing
these huge cultural transitions and and
in who are the the people explaining the
cultural transitions the ones that are
there and one thing that happened so
there's this old village that's
literally coming out of the ground that
maybe it be can say for sure 600 years
I'll let the the village and the
archaeologists say maybe it's even more
than that maybe closer to a thousand
years old but this old yupik village is
coming out of the ground called new
knowledge or the old village and as the
old village is coming out you're
literally a year in there and this has
been going on for over 20 years year
after year the the history and the the
stories all the oral stories are
physically manifesting itself again so
it's the past in that the future that is
the past or the pasta is the future but
it's all coming back and so something
that happened is some of the youth there
I think go through transitions of of how
they identify with their landscape and
who they are and one
one boy Michael walked out to the new
knowledge the old village and he sort of
maybe if my words tripped over an
artifact but I think that's that's
that's my words I think in his words he
found his ancestor and he went back to
the village that had really been in
debate about whether they would actually
archaeologically dig this site and
preserve it he went back and he said
it's it's time to do this and and then
other children said we can hear the
voices and we're going to dance again we
haven't danced in 80 years and the elder
said yes they began to work with other
people - to - to what do you want to say
sort of birth the village again this old
village and and now I went to Mike
that's the boy you saw and I went over
there and he said do you want me to show
you the seal hunting dance and it was
right after it actually was probably the
same day I think it was the same day
that Sarah who I stay with when I when
I'm there
her son Jared brought home the seal and
I she open the seal like this and I'm
looking at her and there's so much ice
you can see like you can for me you see
the transitional time of of relating to
the seal and in the later on that day we
went over and make so let me show you
the seal hunting dance and so that's
what
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so ritual you've seen ritual change over
time oops and and maybe is it fair to
say that ritual helps a culture deal
with change we think of we think of we
tend to think of ritual that's frozen
this is this frozen culture but but
ritual is it a tool that helps people
endure change that comes to their
landscape in their culture I think we
are change so there forward it's a way
to express who we are who is this who do
you think it is I think it's well I've
got a sad answer and a happy answer to
that I think it's a it's a it's a dying
culture looking to the gods for help but
I don't know maybe it's also Erica
do you think yes tell us what it is and
is there a ritual use of it
so okay on this um so in this journey
this is a weapon
bear in mind that it has to happen in 25
seconds well maybe I'll just leave you
guys can maybe figure out who it is I
don't know if I could do that in 20
seconds I'm really good I can't I can't
I guess that's a good place to stop it's
inexplicable thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome photographer and National
Geographic Explorer on news babajanian
[Music]
[Applause]
on October 23rd last year I was standing
in the middle of a cotton field near the
town of Margolin in Uzbekistan
photographing the people around me
myself haven't picked about a kilogram
of cotton by then and I was thinking to
myself yes this is how I'm going to
photograph the story of water in Central
Asia this is going to be part of a chain
of visuals that will bring my story to a
conclusion on another day I was standing
in front of the to yüksel glacier a few
kilometers away from Almaty in
Kazakhstan and that's me and I was
thinking to myself again and even
pronouncing no I don't know what I'm
doing why again am i photographing this
glacier I was lost
not only was I lost my drone was also
lost but in fact I was happy about this
feeling about this state of mind because
I had that feeling that very soon I was
going to find myself and the first lucky
sign of that was that I found my drone
now that question I kept asking myself
was how do I choose to tell a complex
story one that includes layers of
history human interests the environment
and the changing climate culture and
beliefs and enveloping this the all
important resource of water years ago
when the countries of Central Asia were
part of the Soviet Union a system was
implemented to share water after the
system collapsed after the Union
collapsed the system also called
and now there are more issues than
solutions to water management in these
countries the population of Central Asia
is increasing it will grow by 20 million
in the next 20 years with the rise of
population there is more demand for
water global warming is causing longer
irrigation periods and the retreat of
glaciers on the tension and Pamir
mountains it is estimated that there
will be 30% more need for water and at
the same time 30 percent less water by
2030 in Central Asia
now visualizing this was and remains a
continuous process of searching and
making connections for me in Gaza Stan I
photographed at 30 octi a railway
station where villagers took water from
a wagon cistern that arrived to the
village every day and that was the only
source of water for this village both
drinkable and irrigation by the RLC I
met women washing in warm spring water
fountains that appeared as the sea began
to retreat I photographed along the
river ahmad area in Uzbekistan it is one
of the two main sources of water in
Central Asia along with said Darya the
more I photographed the more I studied
and realized for myself how this story
was not only about water at all but also
about people culture survival itself in
this region
these are women returning home after a
day on the rice field very close to
where ahmad area begins 18-year old
de nada on her wedding day in Munich a
former seaport in Uzbekistan during the
days of roaming around the deserts of
the RLC I got to know artemius Salina
shrimp farmers this brine shrimp is so
tiny it is like
it appeared here only recently as the
sea retreated and salinity increased on
our second day by the sea a sheep was
sacrificed in hope for the population of
Artemia Salina to rice I took a number
of photos and then I saw this scene the
brown liquid like RT Mia the blood of
this shape and all around the receding
water of the RL the human interests
spirituality in our environment we're
all in this image this photograph was
nothing I had imagined would happen it
did not even include people and I think
of myself as a people photographer but I
leaned into this image into this visual
feeling that it mattered as much and
that it was as a life and for that
moment I felt I had one little answer
for myself I believe each story needs an
individual approach but also a
photographer's own search through layers
and complexities and as true authors of
our work we need to allow ourselves to
give justice to our findings with our
the realities and the revelations of our
stories and this I say mostly to myself
of course because both mentally and
spiritually and in fact also physically
having two more countries yet to visit
for this project and many more stories
hopefully to tell I'm only just
beginning this journey thank you
ladies and gentlemen there will now be a
20 minute break
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Stephanie's doing a mighty
testing mic 1 2 3 4 testing 1 2 3 4
testing 1 testing two microphone 12
testing 1 2 3 4
and now please enjoy this short film by
National Geographic Explorer Ismael
Vasquez
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
National Geographic Society senior
director for Latin America Kyle
Amida
[Music]
Ismail was born and raised in a small
indigenous community in the southern
part of Mexico that is called sample
Ramos the video that we just saw is in
his native language amused oh and one of
the main characters is his mother is
Maya's goals as a storyteller is to
really portrait a new image of
indigenous communities that can help
them overcome stereotypes and be more
truthful to what they are and what they
and how they live ismail got in December
the Sundance Institute grant to finish
the production of this short film and
he's here with us so I want to ask him
to stand up so that we can give him a
round of applause
[Applause]
and now to continue with our program
please welcome conservation photographer
and expert Ronan Donovan
[Applause]
hello everyone I'd like to start with a
quote this is a quote by the late John
Berger
he was an English novelist and art
critic John said with their parallel
lives animals offer man a companionship
which is different from any offered by
human exchange different because it is a
companionship offered to the loneliness
as man as a species
so to help illustrate John's point show
of hands how many people have ever lived
with an animal in the same house fish
dog cat yeah
it's most of us right there are scenes
like this that is familiar to us a large
animal in a vehicle this is actually my
brother Eamonn with his dog Willem and
Willem was a very clever dog he figured
out really quickly that he could get out
of the vehicle he could just open the
doors you get my brother's truck and he
would jam screwdrivers and different
tools blocks of wood in the door frame
so that Willem couldn't open it up and
so we domesticated this animal the wolf
this is an image by Robert Clarke story
about the domestication of wolves
I think the agent for this Maltese is
going to get some feedback here the
Maltese doesn't look too excited to be
standing under that big animal but
there's an archaeological dig site there
in the corner that shows a skeleton of a
12,000 year old man clutching a puppy so
it's this idea that we have this
connection to this wild animal different
than any other it's the first animal we
domesticated some thirty forty thousand
years ago in Eurasia and so just a quick
overview of the gray wolf in North
America this is a map of their current
and historic range historic range is the
light orange and the darker is their
current range so I live in Montana we
have about 800 gray wolves which is
considered a success just last week was
the
25 year anniversary of the wolves being
brought back into Yellowstone National
Park there's as I said 800 but in the
late 1800s from 1888 onwards every year
on average there were about 5,000 wolf
pelts submitted for bounty claims in
Montana alone there are 5,000 wolves
total in the lower 48 now and why is
that why was this eradication of this
animal so prevalent whereas now we love
it we got rid of the wolf and we
replaced it with the Maltese and various
other things it's because they the same
thing as we do and we fear them and this
is an image I made in Yellowstone my
first project for National Geographic in
2015 and this images of wolves that are
scared of people write as forward-facing
they're kind of fearful of us and we
feel that so they were absent from the
landscape before they were brought back
into Yellowstone as I said 25 year
anniversary bringing Wolves back
Yellowstone was last week and so the
issues around Yellowstone are with the
lifestyle that Westerners brought to and
imposed on the landscape of the West
ranching raising very dumb animals
really we dumb down the wild
counterparts in Eurasia we brought them
to Europe and so they make for easy prey
now and then for wolves on average in
Montana they lose about 50 cows a year
to wolves last winter they lost 30,000
cows to whether it's important to
realize that Yellowstone was created for
the geothermal features features like
this the canary Springs and Mammoth Hot
Springs so the borders were drawn not
for what the wildlife needed what the
ecosystem needed but for what was
convenient to preserve those geothermal
features Yellowstone is a massive
supervolcano average elevation of
Yellowstone is above 8,000 feet so it
means it's very harsh place to be at
winter and so the the idea of
Yellowstone is a blueprint of habitat
for the rest of the west isn't
necessarily accurate because it's this
unique place this volcano but
Yellowstone and the wolf relationship
there is about research and about
tourism and so this is a research
Helicon
Derr that is being flown over a pack of
wolves to put a collar on it a tracking
device on the animal this is Doug Smith
hanging out the helicopter on harness
trying to put a dart in the rump of that
wolf once they get them down they go
through a protocol of general health
checks DNA samples and they put those
callers on these are newer GPS tracking
collars so they can figure out their
movements are they leaving the park very
often how big are their home ranges how
are the packs interacting and what are
they mainly feeding on and so this is a
diorama or a piece of art from a
National Geographic magazine article in
early 2000 showing the difference in
habitat from the wolves being brought
back into the landscape showing that
they have a huge impact on the success
and the health of the landscape one you
have too many elk and the other you have
a more balanced ecosystem when you
replace just a single animal known as a
keystone species and so in Yellowstone I
spent much of my time failing as is the
case with things that are scared of you
I couldn't imagine would be like to try
to chase people down that were scared of
you and try to take their picture there
would be a challenge and your images
would reflect that this is a remote
camera this is a motion triggered camera
so the animal is aware of the camera
they're scared of it they're seeing and
hearing the noise click click click of
this tool and so after this project
ended I really felt a need to understand
more about the the real wolf the wolf
that is not afraid of you and try to
tell a better story about them I never
saw wolf pups I never saw much
socialization going on in Yellowstone
they just weren't relaxed whenever I was
within a couple hundred feet or even a
quarter-mile once they would smell me it
was it was game over and so I knew as
many of us did of this place this is a
cover by Jim Brandenburg the photo and
National Geographic sent Jim Brandenburg
and a biologist named David Meech up to
Ella's Muir Island it's the furthest
northern landmass in Canada it's about
700 miles from the North Pole and this
was a place where the Wolves there had
never had a negative encounter with
humans there
no humans living there permanently there
was no livestock no competition with
humans and so I pitched the project it
was approved went up to this very barren
seemingly landscape that is treeless
it's kind of rolling Badlands prairie
ask feel but it's a place that has a lot
of life obviously and the wolves are
there and other species and so just
quick overview where we're at this is 80
degrees north it's right next to
Greenland and the Wolves there as I said
they don't have any fear of humans and
so instead of using camera traps you can
get in front of them while they're
traveling lie down with a 24 millimeter
lens and they walk past you this was
after spending about three weeks with
this pack of wolves and you could also
use camera traps but you could use them
in more intimate settings at the den and
they ignore it they urinate on it it
becomes part of the landscape you clean
the lens and then you're good to go
and so the pack that I spent the most
time with was this pack this is ten
wolves total there are six adults and
four pups couple down here these are the
shaggy yearlings these two are the
females
they were two-year-olds credibly skilled
huntresses this one one eye he had one
eye and half a tail she was quite a wolf
and the two adults the breeders on the
top there and I'll let them introduce
themselves
[Music]
[Music]
I named them the polygon pack because
these polygons Tundra ponds are
something unique to the High Arctic that
formed over thousands of years and this
was very close to their den site and so
I thought today in a effort to kind of
better introduce us all to the life of a
wolf from here on out I'm going to show
you images that were created on over the
course of two days this was a about 35
to 40 hours that I was spent with them
following them while they were hunting
and pushing on they were very hungry and
I thought that this would just be a way
for us to just dive into a day in the
life of a wild wolf and so the day
started I took about 12 hours to find
them and then once I engage them they
were in the midst of a hunt and they
hunt musk oxen which is a large relative
of the goat males away about 800 pounds
and it is this like Long's dance that
goes on this process it's not what we
think of as like they run in and they
quickly successfully take down an animal
it's a dance that this one lasted for
over six hours where they would push the
herd but the herd also works together to
defend themselves and this is a
obviously a formidable line for the
Wolves to try and penetrate there was a
large male that was associated with this
pack and so most of the time the wolves
are unsuccessful here they're sent
packing and it's an opportunity for the
Wolves also to learn and to figure out
how to hunt these animals the one of the
yearling males he was the largest wolf
by body size but he was not the best
hunter he was awkward he would get in
the way of the other adults he would
kind of stumble around he would come in
at the end when all the work had been
done
and so it's a testament to just how much
they have to learn you know like human
hunters we are born with physical and
mental attributes as humans but we can
hunt many different things but we have
to be taught how and wolves are the same
and so during these hunts the pups are
nearby at this time they were about
eight weeks old and so they're kind of
still long-legged gangly looking things
but they're able to keep up and it's an
important learning phase for them to
watch how the adults move and and learn
to hunt these animals so this one for a
while and then they took a nap they
slept for about seven hours on and off I
did my best to get some rest as well and
then they're on again and what they are
are coercing predators is what wolves
are so meaning they travel the landscape
long distances hoping to bump into some
prey they found these musk oxen again
different herd long ways away but the
musk oxen here kind of had this nice
little fortified wall behind them and
didn't last long the Wolves just tested
him for about 20 minutes
they went down along sea level here this
is along one of the fjords long
Ellesmere and they eventually went up to
over 2,500 feet so the lowest point in
their home range up to the highest they
bumped into another herd this one also
had a very strong male musk oxen you'll
see down at the bottom and in this next
clip the challenge can be that you
really have to respect these guys
they're big they're quick and it's
impressive to see how much the Wolves
obviously respected that this next clip
is going to play all the audio I should
mention is by a Nuke throat singer her
name's Tanya to gawk and this next clip
will just be her voice and music over
the action
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that was one of the two year old
females she end up being fine they
carried on that was just a normal day
for her in her pursuit to try to get
food you know wolves exists in this
strange realm as an animal where they
literally have to put their life at risk
just to eat which there's other
predators that on smaller game than they
do a smaller game than a way and so it's
not as much of a challenge but here we
are carrying on our way here they have
these kind of bulletin board sites I
kind of called them where it's an old
carcass site that they would routinely
visit market smell other wolves that
have maybe come through the area it was
a chance for the young to be able to
figure out the pups if they get lost go
to the bulletin board and figure out
what's going on bumped into a lone male
they thought maybe this would be a nice
opportunity but again these are
relatives of goats the musk oxen and so
they take cover down anything they can
get their back end up against and it was
a quick little - again a couple minutes
just to test to see if you had a limp or
if there was some weakness they could
exploit they carried on check the nearby
bulletin board and then they went for a
different prey that's located on the
island a smaller prey this is a arctic
hare and it looks like a lot of effort
for potentially just a ten pound reward
ten pounds is a large hair mind you but
as you can see they're much more nimble
they're quicker than the wolves are they
did get one but they were all very
hungry and this is the pups trying to
beg to one of the yearlings who doesn't
want to share they go to the old male
try to get him to regurgitate some
pre-chewed meal they broke it up with
some some play after they had at least a
couple bites of food in their belly we
were at this point at about I think 40
miles of distance traveled over the
course of the the two days yeah relieve
some stress play a little bit and then
they were pushing higher in elevation in
their home
and they were going again for more of
these Arctic hares going higher and
higher up along this plateau got it in
some snowy areas and I'll let this clip
play on its own as well
[Music]
looks like a lot of energy for no reward
they seemed hopeful in that chase but it
didn't work out as soon as the hairs go
up to higher ground the Wolves just
can't keep up I can't chase him
so fold them up they crossed over this
pass and they dropped down this narrow
basically avalanche shoot and they all
go over and they pile over and I'm
photographing and the pups go over and I
go to follow them a machine that I was
using as an ATV four-wheeler it's just
like an off-road motorcycle with four
wheels get off that walk over this area
and it's sheer ice it just drops off and
I see these slide marks of all the
wolves and it's too steep it's probably
a 65 70 degree pitch and I think that
they are gone that they must have just
poofed off into a bunch of rocks this is
this was what I thought maybe was the
last photo that I was gonna take in
relation to these animals it took me a
couple hours to figure out a way to get
down this steep plateau hit your point
where I can see their tracks traversing
down that drainage and I think you know
I don't see anything and see any bodies
piled up or anything and I eventually an
hour later find them and they were just
curled up this is just a normal day for
them in the life of these wild wolves
for me it was incredibly challenging
experience all the technology in the
world trying to keep up with them I was
wrecked destroyed exhausted been up for
40 hours photographed and filmed all of
this over the course of that time and
realizing that this is these wolves are
kind of living these present daily lives
in the moment cooperatively working
together to achieve things that they
can't on their own and in many ways
that's the human happy place as well and
in in closing I'm gonna read another
quote this one is by the late Fred
Woodruff mr. Woodruff was an elder with
the quaalude tribe of Northwest
Washington the Olympic Peninsula
and mr. woodruf said we learned from the
wolf how to survive and how to be more
human how to honor our elders to protect
and provide for our families and we
learned from wolves the loyalty you need
to really belong to a tribe thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome wildlife filmmakers and
National Geographic explorers Malaika
Baz and Jehovah Bertolli
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon we're so excited to be
here today
my name is Malaika and I'm a wildlife
presenter and filmmaker and in the last
few years my work is focused on
lesser-known critters for television big
cats as part of mine add to your early
career grant but today I am so excited
to be talking about our shared passion
for the oceans yeah my name is Jerry
Batali I'm an underwater filmmaker but
also a wildlife photographer grew up in
Kenya spent a lot of time out in the
Mara with big cats but my real passion
is the ocean and that's what I've been
focusing my time on now malaika when it
comes to marine stories what is your
focus and why I'm always chosen to focus
on marine trafficking in the last few
years and it's because when I was
spending time out at sea on these
fishing vessels looking for marine
megafauna I realized that we were
treating the oceans as though they were
inexhaustible and when you think of the
word wildlife trafficking he was
sociated with ivory and with elephants
and tigers but people don't often think
about the marine stuff that gets out of
our oceans so for the last few years
I've been making stories that are
focused on marine trafficking in India's
oceans but coming back to you Johar we
I'd love to understand more about why
you do what you do and how it all
started well I was blessed to sort of
grow up in such a diverse and beautiful
country as Kenya and we spent time on
this little while bit of the coast and
you know as a child it was the funnest
thing get up early in the morning run to
the beach and go snorkeling and see what
was going on or at low tide check out
all the little rock falls yeah and it
was an idyllic kind of upbringing but as
I grew older I realized it was changing
when I went out all the little things I
used to go out and see were disappearing
and to the point now it was almost like
a barren wasteland and I was like what
there is so much emphasis on the
terrestrial wildlife in Kenya but no one
is really looking at the oceans and huge
changes are happening in our oceans but
there's also huge amounts of stories to
be found so I started looking into
oceans
and came across this incredible story
about a humpback whale migration that
comes through the Kenyan coast and I was
like I have to make a film about this so
the support of National Geographic we
went outside to try and film the first
sequences of humpback whales in Kenya
and as all good wildlife does they
didn't show up this year but in this
process it's been very exciting because
we were working with communities because
wildlife is one side but there are
people who have been living with these
animals and if you really want to find
the stories you need to work with these
communities so we went into these
villages especially la marca Pedego and
we were interviewing old fishermen and
we were trying to find out old stories
of humpback whales and we did find some
incredible stories but actually what we
found was a much bigger project mm-hmm
because we found that we could actually
tell the story of the changes in the
Indian Ocean from the stories of these
old fishermen and through their eyes and
it's so important when you go into a
community and you want to create
educational material you have to
understand this is their story and
they're the best people to tell it so
we've been now working on this film
we've been interviewing fishermen and
we're now trying to tell the story of
the change
through the eyes of this really old
incredible fisherman and we have a
little it was really quick yes we have a
safety person yeah Bihari
Huna ng Hawaii Bihari Lin nan Jana Nikon
Ambani
eva peron lilleküla Neko nya - nya Lee
vamos ephyra quaternion upto bihari CC
not Rama Hari
padam refugia dearly in a visa from Boca
Lima you are Bihari attuning iguana in
on Akana hyena Mushu liquid medium Aisha
so totally worth video nel alone a
carnauba her equally media so much
[Music]
viola Guara he sang Oleg wanna go
where's Oahu at Illyria Kilohana to talk
abou sir
bikini katika measure on ramayana by
xavier to another alternative Atalissa
nasa see Leo to know
[Music]
like in - now as a KwaZulu issue by the
- prana mudra horrible area - he was
Nash economy corner family
[Music]
me-me-me movie
hakuna key to begin an energy as a final
ether who only had a terrible golfer
believe you
they finally nearly
he's a sneaky gacho it afonya me walk
over here to nakusha cannabinoid thank
you for sharing with back with us and
I'm so excited to see the final
documentary once it's done yes coming
soon
now tell me Malaika was there a moment
that inspired you to tell Erin stories
so I grew up in a small coastal village
in the place in India called Goa and
when I was younger I used to compete in
windsurfing professionally so I would
spend huge amounts of time training in
the ocean and this one time I was all
alone when I was probably 5 p.m. and I
saw this enormous ripple in the distance
and it didn't really look like a turtle
or a dolphin so I had to go closer and
when I went closer I saw this humpback
whale just by hopping out of the ocean
and looking me straight in the eye and
in that moment I was blown away because
I didn't even know that we had humpback
whales in our waters and in that moment
I also realized that I wanted to tell
stories about the oceans as a way to
understand them better not just in my
backyard but across the world amazing
yeah better luck than I did with
humpbacks now I'm sure everyone here
would really like to know what are you
working on at the moment so for the last
three and a half years along with my
best friend and teammate I've been
working on a phone on marine trafficking
with manta rays so we've been following
the trade pipeline from India's Brown
murky waters where people don't even
know we have mantas to the Indo Myanmar
border where I've found through in my
investigation that there are links
between wildlife trafficking and
insurgency in the region and then
finally going undercover in the wildlife
markets of Guangzhou and Hong Kong in
China pretending to be a seafood trader
to understand how much of this
contraband is being sourced from India's
waters the film is in the sports
production stage right now where we have
a little sneak peek as well
my generation was born at the peak of
the world's sixth mass extinction but
for me extinction is something that's
happening in my own backyard
the very first time I saw Monterey I was
diving off a coral reef in the Maldives
I hadn't seen anything like it before
and ever since then mantas have
captivated me like no other species I'm
heading to the spot where there are
large landings of rays so let's see what
we find there and for the past few years
I've been seeing too many manta rays
where they shouldn't be
yeah this is what they're after
predominantly one of the biggest threats
to mantas has been these fisheries for
them where people are actually targeting
animals to be able to extract certain
body parts like gill plates out I've
been tracking the straight down living
with fishermen and witnessing the hunt
out at sea my investigation has taken me
to places that I could have never
imagined we got our information through
a source that there's some contraband
items which are being transported in a
vehicle
I am thousands of kilometers away from
the east coast of India where these
killed plates was so strong at the
Indian border and looking at these bad
stats represent
4250 animals I'm really beginning to
understand the numbers and the
transnational scale industry I've been
to customs warehouses and remote border
towns and track down middlemen and I've
gone undercover in the biggest market
for wildlife products in the world China
you some guys how Allah
Cinzia yeah I'm I'm sorry CJ only
ecology couture go don't be dramatic
you sorry now I are you're gonna build
up your care ten thousand toga once
you've reduced that population down to
fifty twenty ten percent of its of its
natural levels you're looking at decades
and decades for it to recover if if ever
the deeper you dig the bigger it gets
this is the heart of the legal while a
trade and the supply chain points
straight
I mean that that's some pretty
incredible stuff and I mean it's hard to
watch but I have a question is being a
woman in situations like that how is
how's your experience been
to be honest initially Johar we I
received a lot of opposition for being a
woman I remember being told multiple
times by seafood traders that I needed
to get out of there or I would be hot
badly but over time I realized that when
you spend enough time at these fishing
ports and going undercover in these
different wildlife markets you become
part of the furniture and I also
realized that being a woman is such an
asset when you're doing undercover
investigative work because people see
was less threatening so they kind of
invites you into their spaces they take
you into places that some of my male
colleagues wouldn't be taken into but
more importantly they trust you with
their stories they will tell you that
they can you can come into their house
and hear about how they connect with the
ocean and for me that's the most
important part of being a woman in the
field I can tell you my wife gets a much
better reaction than I do coming to you
is your Howie what are the challenges of
filming in the laminal archipelago and
across Kenya well the Lama acapella Go
is an incredibly unique place firstly
because its proximity to Somalia and so
that makes them working in the northern
bit of the archipelago quite challenging
at time so you do have security concerns
which you have to think about we
generally go up in traditional dows and
tend to spend one night and head out and
not spend much time there you never know
what's going to happen but the
archipelago is where two big currents
come through and you've got two big
rivers also coming up so we only have
such a small window of time when we can
get in and film in clear water so on one
side it's very special because it's like
a window into an otherwise unknown
environment but you really have to make
sure you planned out and ready to go
when things happen
so it's pretty pretty incredible so I
know your work also focuses on policy
change now do you think that you can
actually have tangible change through
film I do and I think that to have
tangible change you kind of have to be
really really intentional about the
process of creating impact you can't
just create a provocative film and put
it out into the universe and hope that
you know magical unicorns will help
deliver impact you have to be conscious
of it from the get-go and when I was
making my documentary I realized that a
film alone wasn't a strong enough medium
to push for policy change
so along with a teammate of mine we made
a rough cut of some of the footage and
we took that to the Wildlife Trust of
India which is one of India's best
research and advocacy organizations and
to wild it which is an anti trafficking
organization based in the US and last
year we actually got India's first
baseline data survey on mantas across
the Indian coast so that was really
exciting and when I was filming in the
field in China and in India we actually
had a team of researchers collecting
data every single day and 2020 is the
year where we're going to use both the
data and the documentary to push for
policy change
[Applause]
and jahar we you know we've been friends
for a while and whatever we've had this
conversation about the films that you
make what I'm always struck by is the
fact that the films do you make are with
the people and also for the people so
why do you think this process of making
films accessible is important well it
really comes down to the audience you
want to engage so we're trying to get
people to connect with their ocean you
know and it's one thing to parachute in
and film and go and then come back with
a polished film but really it's their
story we're there to listen to
understand how they view their
environment and whether it's working on
educational films it's about including
the communities you're working in to be
part of the process and what that does
is it creates a feeling of ownership of
this film yeah and people get truly
excited about it I mean we've been
working with fishermen who've never seen
underwater and all of a sudden they see
these clips that we show them they are
so excited and we've had now that
they'll come back and they've filmed
something on their phone and they send
us these little clips and they're like
what's this you know what have you seen
and through this we got the first ever
footage of Risso dolphins confirmed in
Kenya's waters from a fisherman or
Flamel that's amazing so we're making
incredible discoveries and on top of
that now when we're going into community
engagement and through some of the films
have done before we have the actual
community in the lhamo archipelago has
come together because they want to set
up a community marine protected area of
Flamel because they see the benefit of
the ocean and they've fallen in love
with it so we're actually seeing
communities really taking the step and
that is I mean that creates such hope
within me I mean I think it's fantastic
that's incredible and I'm so proud of
you
[Applause]
now do you have hope yes I do so I've
been around for 22 years and I feel like
in the last 22 years alone so much has
changed with our oceans and not for the
better to be honest but at the same time
we've seen so much amazing stuff
happening with researchers and
scientists and students there's been a
groundswell of support for marine
protection in the last two decades so I
am hopeful but the one thing that I
would say is that hope on its own is
cute but hope when married with impact
is the dream team thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome to the stage
photojournalist and national cue